1294 one-man bootleg cat backstage right
now with I want to say the hottest
rapper in the country I mean if I said
that but not a lot of people can argue
with me you know you got man Fetty WAP
bro congratulations thank you I
appreciate that
yeah man you like have so many songs on
the radio like literally I'm on the
radio every day but 3 to 7 and it's like
it is it is Fetty WAP radio real we're
playing again we got the rgf island is
crazy in the club like breath we are
actually low sneak-peek I probably might
drop that I might be number 5 on a chart
word that's the single that's got to be
the next single club out here drop the
mixer everybody sings along to that one
maybe never father to child militia and
those lips September 25th the album is
finally here is self-titled but he walk
the Betty womp
tell me like your writing process
because a lot of people you have such a
knack for writing these books man these
hit records is it like do freestyle is a
written you do it on your phone like
what's your writing process my writing
process I call up people's I called up
young man I called up frizzy I call up
Nicki beats and I'll sing a melody song
like
whatever melody I got my head they send
me a beat the match it I'll go in the
studio and I just come up with some
words that's crazy man that's crazy
so September 25th you're from Paterson
New Jersey Camden which is like country
but how so like you know there's been
guys from New Jersey like red man and
like Joe Budden but I feel like you're
kind of putting jersey on the forefront
of culture that like nobody really has
done that before what how important is
that to you really it's just as a
because I got the chance an opportunity
to show people that it is opportunity
you know I'm saying like no they can
make it you put me like New Jersey
wasn't really a city where you like you
let's go there to find some talent like
yeah right that's we're gonna see the
next hit you know right so forth that
happened for me and prove to them that
it's not only just track clean now is
now is a brand now and I was Fetty WAP
the brand and there
Fetty WAP categories what kind of song
do you want to hear now you gonna I'm
saying and that's what I wanted to
market and basically I feel like BAM
from New Jersey if I can't do it there's
so many other New Jersey artists that
also do it so yeah you're you're you're
becoming like a pop star also like to
thank you because you might have coined
the two best pick-up lines now it's like
you could go up to a girl and be like
hey what's up hello or you got your baby
girl you're so damn fine no i cha cha
[__] I'll do my thing um I saw that
Taylor Swift ought you out on stage yeah
how does that happen they say this with
hits you up like she's like where does
that come from it was mad where cuz like
I said in the interview before that two
weeks prior to her bringing me out on
stage I was I had an interview where um
I want to say was uh Angie Martinez I uh
105 right yeah 105 and I told she asked
me like who do you wanna work right now
and I mentioned telestroke was number
one I was like yeah I want to work with
Taylor Swift like I wanna do some
different she'll bring me on my element
and then two weeks later I'm performing
in front of 60,000 people would you guys
have a conversation like yo the Taylor's
just say yo what you said on there my
way that line that's my [__] like you
know a lot of you
can't imagine Taylor Swift all I know is
she mad cool a really really straight
like business business minded like she
put oh well like we was on stage bro you
woulda thought she was like manager in
the stage like managing the stage and
managing everything moving you know what
I'm saying that when it came time to be
a performer she was a performer so it
was like I kind of took pointers in that
you know I may like to to learn how to
learn how to do both at once
and I mean I miss your girl person real
cool person lit up though what has been
the best part about Sauron on this tour
there's so much talent Chris Brown I
mean I told everybody it's crazy to me
that you're you you didn't go on before
Chris Brown because we have people
calling us they didn't even ask for
Chris Brown say cuz they were like yeah
we want Fetty WAP tickets but what is
the tour been like man it's like Chris
Brown is like you know our age is
Michael Jackson here I'm saying this
it's a lot of talent how's the tour been
[__] honestly the best part is it sort
of me is to go out stage with my
brothers like no man just saying that
y'all get everyday like you know you
know wake up that Paterson New Jersey
and be like yo and twenty-five years
when I turned 23 I'ma be on tour Chris
Brown do the ready boys drink anything
but Remy no I couldn't give them a shot
of fireball that they wouldn't fireball
if I hung their private Osen but they
will do it for the middle well you know
the album's coming out September 25th
Montana bucks one on the album that's
all that's it
you know need everybody to do it like
I'm not downgrading anybody you know say
about the same time only nobody helped
me
going on their own like Drake hopped on
my way but that song was out of here
already like yeah straight up man - for
them I appreciate that you mention it
shout out to his SoundCloud
being like this or if you just need a
new source of music and go to my first
play let it rock this pop it fatty white
bronze you better Congrats on everything